we're just gonna move forward
and uh see where things take us and for
shaina mokler what's next is a baby
following her now ex-boyfriend matthew
rondo's recent arrest for domestic
violence
it's over because i'm never going to
talk to her again on thursday the 46
year old model released a statement to
people that she recently learned some
big news shayna reveals quote i took a
pregnancy test and it is positive this
has been a very difficult week but i'm
taking everything day by day et has
reached out to shayna's reps for comment
of course the former miss usa is already
a mom sharing two kids with ex-husband
travis barker 18 year old son landon and
16 year old daughter alabama shayna also
has a 22 year old daughter atiana with
ex oscar de la hoya
my kids are are my priority and i want
them i want them to be happy and as long
as they are then i'm happy but what
should be exciting news comes amid
ongoing drama with shayna's estranged
beau
so
it's over
okay
i'm completely heartbroken one hundred
percent a complete [ __ ] sociopath
narcissist i have never been
disrespected and so [ __ ] humiliated
in my entire life just hours after
taking over shayna's instagram account
with that disturbing live video et
confirmed matthew's arrest following an
alleged physical confrontation between
the couple turns out the incident
happened on the same night as the finale
for celebrity big brother which shayna
competed on i'm definitely going to say
the celebrity big brother house is one
of the toughest things i've ever done
during the model's time on the show
reports surfaced that matthew was not
happy with her interactions with male
house guests but jaina told et it wasn't
an issue after her elimination there are
reports that you've unfollowed each
other and that there's some some drama
going on can you set the record straight
um sure right now um
i haven't been on social media i have
had someone running my social media for
me so i don't know what's going on there
but um right now um everything is good
and we're working on things and we're in
a good space and we're just gonna move
forward
and see where things take us okay so you
and matthew you're on you're still
together things are good
at the moment yes fast forward to
february 24th and matthew was charged
for felony domestic violence in a
statement to e.t a rep for the reality
star described the incident as horrible
and traumatic but noted shayna is asking
for space to adjust to life after this
trauma that same day alabama shared on
instagram she was in communication with
her mom and gave assurance shayna is
okay and check out the pair on tuesday
hanging out and smiling for the camera
[Music]
you